welcome to this video I'm playing the
tooth pick up from the US nah king of
previous yeah very quickly played wow
wow this my said that must be the
biggest crap ever if you can refute it
in six seconds maybe it is I don't know
it looks a bit strange down okay maybe
take him and let's see what he what he's
trying to do him Knight takes d5 if I
take here what are you doing to like
taking with the poem yes yeah because I
should attack the night and try to force
some sort of concession he has a weak
porn on your form so what I don't think
you should should should take or play a
slow move maybe Bishop g5 and not clear
Bishop f4 might be might be a move
that and I must take then maybe with the
bishop and then we should be six okay
that's um yeah yeah it's always subjects
rookie on this diagonal so it's um when
I was hesitating a bit ok so it's
directly going into a bad end game
that's nice it's a bad end game because
of the four porn and potentially worse
bishop at my king us in as an issue so
yeah maybe maybe it's not so terrible
you can get to d5 with the notices of
course helpful okay he knows 95 and if
he recaptures with the rook then this is
not not so easy to play
Roxy 80 maybe plays Bishop h3 mmm yeah
that's not it's not so easy
I just need some stability em then it's
it's absolutely fine maybe I need to do
that to make sure that there's a pawn
emerging on d5 now 95 years just met
again because now the default is safety
located I just need to exchange look now
and rooks now and win I hope that this
is this is manageable the point is that
the d5 pawn is just to weakness rookie 6
is the only possible way to get counter
play but it does not seem so maybe
rookie 6
maybe but he's just a very just
continuing to play some quick moves mmm
not so clear what's best here
can also regroup try to flick in 93 hmm
rookie 52 x take that's not sauce was
not so convincing I'm not quite sure how
to how to continue I cannot easily gain
control over and over the e-file
yeah for a couple of moves if you just
click on play rocky six but it seems he
never wants to do that so I'm just
playing like this possibility is not
existing the ideal would be rocky six
takes checking takes and then Bishop c6
activating the bishop but it's not doing
that it seems mmm I am NOT summary not
sure how to how to continue maybe ninety
seven months my 97 that says there's
only rupee six now it's doing it check
for whatever reason
check came go here and now it's bishop
is active I probably need to go here
King d6 rookie 6 is not so fortunate
yeah buh bah I'm not sure ninety-five
was also possible takes and a form yeah
now that it would be helpful to have
more time but okay so trying to
calculate this really but need to rely
on your instincts with this little time
Knight takes Candice's may be easier to
play with before coming check trying to
to exchange
and who is taking ages
check
yeah I met on the clock now that's
really not usual
yeah check I really don't want to take
all your pawns I can assure you I'll
take them all czech girl Alfred yeah for
sure you probably wanted to resign Jack
didn't hit the right button
check white forfeits on time yeah it
wasn't so easy a many mate really some
pretty big positional mistakes it's
really cool to play all the stuff
instantly ok so we be grew went here
yeah Bishop f4 would be interesting but
ok let's let's just share and look at
the check the engine my first reaction
was that I'm I'm already substantially
better here because of the bed bishop
and the pawn weakness but this counter
play here is pretty big with Knight to
g5 so I took lots of time here to to
play this move and now 95 is just a big
position a mistake check just leads to
leads to a good play for black after
that it's very one-sided and the
computer is hugely under estimating
blacks echium ok the only question is
how to how to make progress now it's not
not so so self-evident it's got lucky
six that's clear maybe I need some some
other move then when c4 I don't think
that this is terrible but maybe there's
something better the thing is I only
need to exchange rooks and then d5
faults it's not so easy though to do it
I was thinking about this smooth good
after that he gets this counter play so
this is not good after this cisco d6 and
Dwight is sound completely ok this is by
rookie five wasn't good so not easy
computer wants to do this smooth and
then night see phone yeah let's see this
the CSS is correctly +1 porn for black
the Sun make sense with rookie 6 being
the best move yeah after that team he
finally went for the porn sec 2 activity
but here Bishop c6 was what I was
thinking about more I can take Roxy
eight okay it's also not not too late
check yeah okay well here the the count
the portcullis severely reduced check
the rogue traders of course a big
mistake I mean very check this should
should be should be winning I think I'm
very close to the pawns and he can
defend better of course I mean he like
Bishop e2 for example is a better
defense preventing kingi for Jackie
Bishop everyone and so on I don't know
there are some some better ways to to
defend very interesting is this position
really where it's not so clear how to
proceed maybe really h5 intending this
age for move this is maybe this is the
best the best way to play now the
computer wants to wants to play this
line check and now here to keep
counterplay to a minimum if i take i can
also take why not
yeah that's the chick I mean maybe maybe
just go here it's a it's not necessary
to take that yet I have rope d8 now as a
possibility yeah that's a very
uncomfortable position four ID okay
thanks for watching